The joe rogan experience.
A lot of us get there,
right?
A lot of people that we know came from
a place where when they were really
young,
they were like,
what the fuck is going on with the world?
Yep.
Wait,
how old were you?
Do you think you were
when you had your first,
Oh,
I think my parents might
be fucking crazy thought.
What do you like?
These people are in charge
of telling me what to do.
This is nonsense.
You make,
you do,
you're talking crazy talk here.
It happens.
It happened for me,
uh,
the first time that I took a Lsd,
and maybe before that,
but when I took Lsd,
I,
when I took LSD for the first time,
I can remember when,
whenever you take Lsd,
uh,
especially,
you know,
I mean at the,
when I took Lsd,
what worries do I have?
I'm in fucking high school.
There's no,
there's nothing in there.
There's nothing to,
there's no demons to come swimming out
of my brain and taught me with like all
the myriad of things you
get when you're older.
There's fucking nothing.
You were just open.
I might,
I might be upset cause like a
cheerleader that came over to my house,
I couldn't figure out how to kiss her.
Maybe that's like the biggest
problem I'm having at the time.
So,
but I,
you know,
at that time,
when I did it for the first time
and had that initial experience,
uh,
you know,
when you go back to your
parents who've never taken it,
and if you mentioned it to
them that you'd even taken it,
they might want to put you in a drug
rehab or they think you're insane or they
think you're getting down the wrong track.
You're forced into this place of like,
fuck man,
I can't,
I,
you w you guys don't even,
you don't even know you,
you don't even understand this,
this a new way of experiencing life.
You know,
so,
and I think there's a lot of people who
spend their whole lives never knowing
that you don't have to take
psychedelics to get to that place.
There's other ways to get to that place.
But yeah,
it's a very strange thing.
And those people who
never get to that place,
they're the ones who are,
a lot of them are,
are in control.
Right.
So your life took inexorable change when
you did acid that was like the point
where you look back and you said,
this is the point where I
went off into this direction.
Um,
well I know I'd say the,
the,
that,
that taking acid started
with a series of like books.
It started with contact with like,
you know,
the whole weirdness.
My whole weird weirdness started with,
as I recall,
it started with me coming upon this
book that my mom had called Raja Yoga by
Yogi Rama terracotta,
who by the way,
it was never a Yogi was
just some English mistake.
Okay.
Wide about being a Yogi.
But it's a fascinating story.
But the book,
uh,
you know,
that was the first time
I'd ever read the idea.
They,
you there that you're an
observer observing yourself,
that you,
you aren't necessarily the you,
that you think the you,
that can be observed is not you.
You're the observer state,
the mindfulness,
the watcher.
That's when I,
that's the first time I'd come upon
the idea of what that's called,
the amen.
The thing that observes yourself.
You know,
when you,
you know someone say,
I'm really mad right now.
The moment you say I'm mad,
you're creating a distinction.
You know,
between the thing that's
observing that you're mad.
And the thing that's mad.
So that observer,
that watcher,
that's the thing that,
that mindfulness is what,
you know,
throughout my whole life,
I try to,
you know,
go into that place of observing
myself rather than being the thing.
And it's a game that you can play in.
It really is quite
helpful with a variety of,
of problems,
especially if you get really angry.
If you get really angry and you can
stop yourself and just watch and there's
tools you can use.
In that book.
I remember it said as you walk around,
start thinking he is walking.
That was like one of the tools,
like it's in a book and
you're a character in a book.
So when you're going around,
you're like,
you know,
right now he's doing a podcast right now.
He's talking.
And so that's,
these are,
these are activities
designed to create this,
like the watch or the state
of presence of watching.
So that started it.
That led me to like,
you know,
I,
and then I found out about,
you know,
I,
uh,
I think I read the
electric koolaid acid test,
you know,
about fucking a Ken Kesey and the merry
pranksters blasting themselves on acid
and going to the world's fair in a bus.
And then I read that shit.
No,
I remember,
wait,
I'll tell you and then
I'll stop this weird,
weird rant.
I remember now.
Fucking filmstrip that's
what it started in my head.
I think I was in like fourth
grade and they showed us a drug.
Filmstrip remember film
strips fucking popped up.
This guy like it hot.
There's a guy I still going,
right?
It's a guy in it.
It's a guy in a fucking,
um,
empty apartment and he's curled against
the law and the fetal position and it's
an LSD and it looks terrible.
And then the narrator says,
Lsd can make you
experience hallucinations.
You can see dragons.
And I remember him saying,
you could see drag.
I'm like,
I don't want to see if
you see a track that sounds awesome.
Fuck the UPL empty apartment.
The fetal position.
I'll figure it out.
Sit on that guy's a pussy.
Like what are you crying?
So dragging a little bit.
It took acid and jigs
back in and that was,
that.
Put it in my head is like,
well you know,
I think that that's an
interesting thing to explore but
oh that's hilarious.
So you think that you were
like to Dunkin's like Dunkin
one and Dunkin to like
Dunkin one is like
regular Dunkin growing up,
innocent boy.
Sure.
Boom.
Psychedelics and then Dunkin 2.0
yeah.
Yeah there's definitely a Dunkin to that.
That happened I'd say.
And then that,
that Dunkin to change too man.
Cause you,
you know,
as you get older,
the best thing,
there's two great,
the best thing that can happen
to use you get knocked off track.
That's the best thing that
can happen to you in general.
Cause generally the track you're on has
been set for you by people who never got
off their track.
You end up,
you know,
you end up the child of someone who
decided to have you in their twenties 2122
they're not going to know a lot of stuff.
They're not going to understand the
universe that much unless they were like
came from a really good family
of artist are intelligent people.
Chances are they're scared,
hungry,
desperate,
angry.
They don't want to be in
the relationship anymore.
They don't want to be monogamous anymore.
The idea of non monogamy to
them might just seem insane.
The,
you know,
like who the fuck knows?
But you're born into that planet.
That's the atmosphere you're born into.
That's what you're breathing
when you're first born.
And that can set you on a weird path.
And that's a very sad
path that you can get on.
And so hopefully if you're lucky,
you'll come across.
Somebody knocks you off that fucking path.
You know,
I remember the guy who
hooked me up with acid.
I remember sitting in the theater
of my school cause I was taking,
I was at drama nerd and I sitting in the
theater of my school next to this guy
next to this Guy Brad.
And uh,
I remember sitting and I,
and we're talking and he
mentioned tripping on Lsd.
And I'm like,
what?
It's like,
oh yeah,
I took acid over the weekend.
I'm like,
well what you can get acid,
the movie,
the life,
the life of somebody must
animate this somebody please.
I know your folks out
there that animates shit.
You got to animate this,
that,
that moment took me two,
and this is really weird.
Tell me what the,
the first trip was like.
God,
I love to,
the first trip was it was white blotter,
white blotter paper.
I don't,
it was just white bladder,
a little Pete,
you know,
somehow if you don't know this,
LSD gets put on sheets which
just look like blotter paper.
And sometimes they have designed,
sometimes they don't.
But the name is always a reference to
usually as a reference to the design on
the sheet.
So,
uh,
you know,
purple,
Jesus,
White Blotter of lips,
you know,
there's a million different names
for the different types of acid,
but,
so this is just white.
You who knows what it was,
but it was really good and
I can remember I took it
and you have to,
you know,
it takes 30 to 45 minutes
sometimes longer for it to kick in.
I still remember I was sitting
in my friend's trailer in
a trailer park in North
Carolina sitting in an empty bathtub,
like when it like an empty Jacuzzi
tub that was in this trailer.
And I'm sitting there and they're
watching star wars and I'm sitting in this
bathtub and all of a sudden the greatest,
it's the greatest feeling just started
going through my legs and up into my
body.
And it was a fucking sword fight.
It was a a lightsaber fight
when I'm listening to that.
But all of a sudden now the sounds echoey,
like someone's turned an echo up on it.
So I was like,
yeah,
well,
you know,
parents kind of bouncing around.
It's beautiful.
And I feel so fucking
good started laughing.
It seems so funny.
Then I went outside and lay in the grass.
I'm staring at the sky.
Everything's beautiful trails.
You put your hand in front,
your face and it's just this rainbow of
hands drifting in front of your face.
Everything's breathing.
Then my friends come running out because
they knew this is the first time I was
tripping and they all
start jumping over me.
They're like jumping over me as I'm laying
there and they're laughing and we're
all fucking laughing
and it's just perfect.
Then I remember they
pulled their cock out.
That's when they pulled that.
When we all started fucking,
we fucked and fucked and then a dog came
by and we grabbed the dog and started
fucking the dog.
No,
no know.
It was beautiful.
Very now.
Yeah,
there was no fucking happening.
There was a lot of like laughing.
There is a,
I remember going into my friend's shitty
high school car and like sitting and
like pulling the seat back and looking
at the ceiling and I'm looking at the
ceiling and it's fucking hieroglyphics
or some kind of like ancient writing,
you know?
I don't even think I knew
what Sanskrit was at the time,
but I'd probably be like,
oh,
I'm seeing Stan script.
Some kind of runes are glyphs all over
my friend's car that she's kind of
breathing and warping
and it's just beautiful.
So yeah,
that was the,
that was the first time.
And once you've had that experience,
how do you go back to a world,
a normal kind of world?
First time I ever did acid.
I've,
I've told you this
before I met Kurt Cobain.
How crazy was that?
Whoa.
Wow.
Tell the story again.
I think I died this night,
by the way.
I have this very,
that know that this is what made me think
of a theory that like every time you
die you don't know that you died.
But then you left this rural,
then everyone else in
this other parallel road,
you know,
they think you die.
Like,
you know,
went to the funeral.
And this is where I thought this one was.
Uh,
the first time I did acid,
me and my girlfriend at the time,
and it was Marissa.
We went to go see,
we went to go see a nirvana
and she had acid and I,
I've never done it before.
She goes,
let's do acid and see nirvana.
So we took acid and the
opening band was on,
which,
which is some Asian band that
just screamed the whole time.
And it was like,
ah,
you know,
it's kind of like,
I don't know,
annoying.
So I was sitting next to the side of the
stage and Kurt Cobain comes around the
corner and it just comes out.
It like it was really dark
so no one could see it.
And he's just standing right next to me.
I look over,
I'm like,
oh my fucking God,
it's Kurt Cobain.
And I was like,
Hey,
what's up?
And he goes,
hey,
you went to Chico?
And he like,
like hold out his bag.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And then so I held on the cheeto
and then suddenly he just like,
somebody goes,
oh Kurt.
And then he just like throws all the
Cheetos out in the crowd and the,
they cause returns backstage and I'm
holding this cheeto and I'm like,
drew the Cheetos.
The crowd.
Yeah.
Like he had a bag of Cheetos
that he was eating for him.
He just threw it at the crowd.
Yeah,
he just threw Cheetos everywhere.
I mean it was,
this is like a mosh pit in Dayton,
Ohio side of the stage,
like a rock club,
you know,
hair arena.
I think it was a fucking video of
Dana white getting in a mosh pit.
No,
he went to a range in the machine,
rage against the machine concert
and motherfucker got an a mosh pit.
She gets security guards were going out
for him when she jumped in a mosque.
So I took this cheeto and
I put it in my pocket.
I'm like,
I'm going to save this Cheeto,
you know,
uh,
and then I start,
you know,
tripping really hard and hadn't was
that amazing concert on the way home.
We're driving and we go by in like,
I'm driving it and this
is a thunderstorm or rain.
I'm still tripping,
tripping,
tripping on acid.
And then this is even better.
And I swear to God that you could ask her.
I'm not going to say who she is.
I'm on here,
but we started fucking while I was
driving in the rain storm on acid for my
first time,
you fucking baby and that's where
I think I died the first time.
One of the first times I died.
It might be okay.
Oh Shit,
iTunes or recording to
server the fuck outta here.
Server.